all right thank you uh having um Joan
used to write I'm actually still digging
out the exact wording of the question so
can I paraphrase slightly or take a best
guess at the wording
thank you
thank you
so my question is do the counselors
believe that in the context of their
role they are doing all they can to
respond to the climate crisis
thank you
thank you very much Mr Roberts I call
upon councilor Bob bayford to respond
chairman and thank you Mr Roberts for
your question
TDC called a climate emergency on the
11th of July 2019 an officer working
group and a cross-party councilor
working group were filmed to initiate
actions on the first environmental
action plan
all of the actions within this plan have
been completed and that included adding
increased Energy Efficiency measures in
the local plan all developments over 10
units must have an EV charging point an
air quality in Senate has now improved
to meet all UK standards
in December 2021 the working group was
changed to a cross-party cabinet
Advisory Group to advise to produce a
net zero strategy and action plan
focused specifically on the reduction of
greenhouse gas emissions
the new net zero strategy was published
this month and is now in a period of
public engagement behind this strategy
is a full action plan involving all
directors and managers of the council
I monitored this action plan every month
and the climate change cabinet Advisory
Group monitors it every two months and
Council will also get a chance to
monitor progress each year we've also
said have an external auditing process
The Net Zero strategy not only covers
our aim to reach Net Zero by 2030 in our
Estates and transport but also addresses
emissions and installation in our social
housing and thanet wide housing helping
to address the cost of living crisis and
climate change at the same time
in the past year the cast has also
addressed the ecological emergency by
planting Wildflower Meadows and trees we
planted 42 standard trees in Jackie
Bakers and we'll plant a thousand young
trees in Ramsgate Parks this month with
children from Ford Junior schools
residents will also be able to get
involved with planting planting a
further 58 trees in November at the war
Recreation ground and nethercote Park I
personally I hope counselors agree think
that we're doing a brilliant job with
the resources we currently have thank
you
thank you very much councilor bayford
thank you Mr Roberts
I move on to agenda item seven questions
from members of the council in total
nine questions have been received from
members of the council for this evening
note that the time allowed Focus
rotation of questions from the members
shall not exceed 30 minutes however
given the circumstances I will be
flexible about this as I usually am but
I do ask members to be as succinct as
possible
gender item 7i question number one from
a member regarding maintenance of
Memorial monuments I call upon councilor
Crittenden councilor Crittenden
thank you
chair it's for councilor Pugh why has
this Council ceased to provide adequate
maintenance and care of the memorials
and monuments for which it is
responsible including grade two listed
structures in accordance with the
decision of cabinet in October 2005 and
what is proposed to rectify this
situation
thank you councilor critzerland
councilor Pugh are you able to respond
I am chat and uh thank you councilor
Christian for your question the council
has limited resources to undertake
maintenance work on its portfolio of
property assets and as a consequence
maintenance programs have been reduced
and priority given to the most
significant buildings and assets and to
health and safety related works we are
reviewing the council's assets including
listed structures so that we can move to
a more sustainable position across the
whole portfolio
which potentially includes generating
additional income disposing of buildings
and assets that are no longer required
or working with town and Parish councils
or other partners to explore the
transfer of assets where this is
appropriate the property director I've
been informed and met with Council
Crittenden on the 31st of August to
discuss the destiny statue cleaning
works and The Wider possible transfer to
town councils of statues and ancient
monuments and their subsequent
maintenance and repair in some
circumstances the transfer of structures
such as listed monuments to Parish or
town councils May mean that necessary
maintenance could be completed more
quickly
thank you councilor councilor Crittenden
do you have a supplementary question
with a mind question thank you ah right
well that's shortens things gender item
7B question number two from a member
regarding graffiti in Ramsgate and
Margate car Parks uh this one's from
Hugh councilor Alban you're right chair
thank you
um this is for a question for Council of
Pew again
um the states of the multi-story uh the
multi-story car parks in Ramsgate and
Margate are disgusting can you please
confirm that action will be taken to
thoroughly clean and remove graffiti as
soon as possible thanks Jeff thank you
Council Alabama Council appeal you're in
the wars this evening over to you thank
you chair I am but I don't mind it's
fine uh thank you Council Auburn for
your question the car parts have been
subjected to significant graffiti
attacks over the summer months and these
have been reported to our minor Works
team for removal and or painting over
offices from our CCTV team have also
undertaken removal of the offensive
graffiti within Mill Lane as it has
occurred all of these incidents have
been reported to Kent Police for
investigation including CCTV images of
the offenders during the summer season
resources have been redirected to high
priority areas our cleansing team will
now return to normal service and we'll
visit the car Parks three times a week
to complete generally to picking and
deep cleans scheduled in twice a year
the next one is due to be completed this
month and this is coordinated with waste
and recycling to ensure that the sites
are swept before deep cleaning and I
would also add cancer Auburn that whilst
I agree that the car parts can get in a
particularly nasty State I think it's
important that we recognize that the
council is doing the best they can to
maintain them and keep them clean but
you know really the responsibility also
rests with the people that want to trash
them in the first place and have no
respect for any public buildings but uh
thank you
thank you councilor Pugh it is a problem
Council Auburn do you have a
supplementary question I do share
um I thank councilor put for his answers
and our supporters view certainly about
the uh about the people responsible for
the
graffiti so I've basically got a
two-part question chair
um in relation to the Royal Harbor uh
multi-story car park and that is
um is the council going to continue with
the lease of the car park
and secondly uh can you be advised as to
when the lifts will be
um
operational thank you very much
councilor Saunders um as they've been
out of action for a good year and a half
or so thank you chair
s councilor Alban I don't feel it's
directly related to the first question
and therefore I'm really leaving to
council Pew as to whether or not he
wishes to respond on that
thank you Chan thank you councilman all
I was going to say was that let's take
this away I'll seek an update from
officers and let's see what we can find
out and uh and I'll get back to you
point of order chair uh yes councilor
Owen uh I I don't think you were you
were right share
um in in my opinion it was in in
relation to both the car parks and I've
got a supplementary question about a car
park so how can that be out of order I
didn't say it was out of order Council
Auburn I said it was in my opinion
unrelated and as chair my opinion is
what matters here
I respect what you have to say but
notwithstanding I stand by what I've
said so thank you councilor open as soon
as you're as soon as you're the governor
chair and I'll uh I'll I will take that
on board thank you chair thank you very
much indeed Council agenda item 7c a
question number three from a member
regarding local housing allowance levels
I call upon Council of Whitehead
thank you chair
in light of our current housing crisis
what interventions are planned for
Central recognition of the fact that our
lha rates are currently utterly
insufficient for the property demands of
our area thank you
thank you very much indeed councilor
Whitehead a call upon councilor Jill
bayford to respond
thank you chair and thank you councilor
Whitehead for the question
the council Works closely with local
landlords and letting agents with the
aim of ensuring that the private rented
sector continues to make a valuable
contribution to meeting the housing
needs of the district and to support
households that need assistance with the
housing circumstances to access suitable
and affordable private sector tenancies
increases in private rented sector rents
have made this work much more
challenging it's increasingly difficult
for households on low incomes to find
suitable and affordable homes in the
private rented sector
this is due both to both rent increases
and to pressures on the supply of homes
in the private rented sector
it's Cabinet member for housing I have
specifically written to the minister for
housing at the department of leveling up
and local government to raise concerns
about our local housing pressures in my
letter I specifically stated that the
current upward pressure on private
sector rents now means that over 80
percent of the properties available in
in the private rented sector have rents
above the local housing allowance rate
and in particular the 30 percent 30
percentile rent which was pre has
previously been the basis for local
housing allowance is 31 Pounds 41 per
week above the local housing allowance
for rate for the area
this position is clearly not sustainable
for many households a large part of the
response to this is the council's
ongoing commitment to the direct
provision of new affordable homes
since April 2021 this work including the
council's own development program has
seen the number of new affordable homes
delivered increased to 126 in 2021 sorry
21-22 with a further increase to 314
homes projected to be completed during
22-23
these programs will not be sufficient on
their own and we do therefore need to
continue to seek increases in the local
housing allowance rates for Bennett
to that end specific reference to this
issue was included in the report on
housing delivery that was considered a
Cabinet on the 22nd of September the
recommendation to further raise this
issue with central government was agreed
thank you very much councilor bayford
Council Whitehead do you have a sex uh
supplementary
I do chair thank you
um firstly thank you to councilor
bayford for the response
I do recognize the importance of the
delivery of both Council and genuinely
affordable housing
but it is still a very long-term
approach and
we are in crisis now
currently the lha rate for a
three-bedroom house is 797 pounds and 81
Pence a month
a search yesterday brings up only five
properties within Margate that under 1
200 pounds a month
which means that
the requests to central government are
particularly urgent I know that we have
both written regarding the lha rates I
know that we've both written over an
extended period now so my secondary
question is simply have they responded
because the situation we are in now is
unsustainable thank you
thank you councilor Whitehead with a
matter that all of us recognize
councilor bayford have you able to
respond to that supplementary
receive a response to my first letter I
believe you haven't yet received one is
that so
um I haven't received a response to my
letter I know of the response to your
letter previously I was referring
principally to the last referral of
cabinet in terms of addressing the
relevant Minister because the lha rate
was also included in the requests yeah
this this has not yet been delivered
thank you no Ripple
that seems to have cleared that up a
general item 7D question number four
from a member regarding EV charging
points I call upon councilor Bailey
councilor Bailey
thank you
my question is to councilor Bay for Bob
bayford regarding the absence of public
electrical vehicle charging points in
broadstairs specifically there are two
public charging points in Ramsgate two
in Margate plus rapid charges in Margate
and birchington but to date nothing in
broadstairs
I have been asked by residents about the
lack of provision in broadstairs and
when the council's Net Zero strategy and
action plan is being launched surely
this should be
um a priority now
buying an electric car is a big
commitment and one of these one of the
considerations in making that decision
is the availability of charging points
not only residents but also many of our
visitors abroasters also rely on the
availability of these Transit points
so could you please tell me where we
stand currently and when we can expect
to see public electric vehicle charging
points in broadstairs please thank you
thank you councilor Bailey councilor Bob
bayford
yes thank you chairman and thanks for
your question Council Bailey
um AV charging points have historically
been installed across the district as
and when Government funding has been
available our current charges in the
multi-story car parks are out of
contract and we are working with Kent
County Council on a new scheme across
the district we're at the point of
signing contracts and therefore
installation should begin within the
next few months as part of this new
contract we will be installing charging
points in Albion Street car park in
broadstairs
there's an expectation across the sector
that as electric cars become more
popular that the number of charging
points will increase across the country
then as a whole has a large quantity of
EV points in various settings such as
supermarkets and petrol stations as a
local Authority we will continue to look
to increase those available in our car
Parks since 2018 we've also been
requesting EV points as part of new
developments
there's currently government funding
available for parish and town councils
to install EV charging points in their
own car Parks or publicly available
spaces and we've notified town and
Parish councils of that and hope they
will act on it
The council's Net Zero strategy was
approved for public engagement on the
22nd of September there will be a period
of public engagement for local people to
comment on the proposed strategy and
actions two of the actions within
priority eight of this strategy are to
one complete installations of the
currently funded electric charging
points across the district and two to
create a future plan for EV charging
points on TDC owned land as part of the
parking strategy review
we will also look for opportunities to
install EV charging points as part of
our housing new build program and
suitable referredness sorry suitable
refurbishment projects for our housing
stock where this is possible thank you
thank you councilor Beaufort and very
thorough I come back to you uh councilor
Bailey for a supplementary
um well I'd just like to say thank you
very much that's good news about Albion
Street car park if if and when that
occurs I was just quite disappointed to
read it was a recent report from the DFT
which said than it had the least number
of public
vehicle charging points by some way so
I'm hoping that we can catch up with the
rest of these Ken thank you
well thank you councilor Bailey I didn't
actually get a supplementary question
from you uh
so I can't well call back on councilor
bayford unless he would like to respond
to not a question
no yeah I don't think he does
agenda item 7e question number five
remember regarding electric vehicle
charging Point again I call upon
councilor wing
I'm going to read my question but I
think councilor bayford has actually
answered the question so it might be I
read my question and then go straight to
my response if that's okay my question
the recent hey car report concerning
electric vehicle vehicle sales indicates
a rapid growth in both battery electric
vehicles and hybrid electric vehicles
which in 2021 represented 18.5 of all
new vehicle sales
this upward Trend and clear ground
demand continued into 2022 with March C
in the highest volume of registrations
ever recorded in a single month
the electric vehicle Market is simply
booming and will continue to accelerate
outstriping diesel vehicle sales by the
end of 2022.
Department of Transport data published
in January 22 put at sorry January 2022
puts than it in the bottom 20 to 40
percent of local authorities in terms of
electric vehicle charging provision
how many electric charging points have
than it District Council provided for
public use where are they and do we have
any plans to increase provision given
the rapidly grown demand I actually
think that councilor bayford answered
that question so can I go to my response
councilor Wing he has intimated he would
like to come back at you on it which is
generous and should be looked forward to
thank you
counseling thank you for your question
I've got good news news bad news and
better news
the good news is that we have installed
some electric vehicle charging points
the news is that there's only four the
bad news is they're not currently
working
but the better news is that they will be
fixed under the new contract
thank you thank you short and sharp now
we can move on to your supplementary
thank you
my supplementary EV charging points will
be an important part notice I've got EV
in so it's definitely relevant important
part important part of part of the
parking review when will this start and
will it engage with residents Ward
councilors and other stakeholders badly
affected by present parking issues
thank you very much councilor being back
to you councilor bayford
German unfortunately counts the wing
parking isn't my portfolio so I can't
tell you when it's going to start I'm
sure one of the cabinet members could
but I think shortly I'm sure that we
will you know take into account what
Public's views are and what councilors
views I mean we've always when we've
done things like parking reviews
certainly involved cross-party members
in the committee what I will say though
is that quite coincidentally in recent
review of the action plan that we're
doing it was agreed with Chris Blundell
and the climate change officer and
myself that we would actually seek to
move EV charging points in their
provision further up the agenda and
start to put pressure on KCC play a
major part in the provision of this
we've got a regular dialogue set up with
their cabinet member and their lead
officer we should be having another
meeting with them in November and
certainly EV points will be a major part
of that discussion I know the cases
you've got some ideas and hopefully they
will be to the benefit of thanet thank
you
thank you councilor B for today I'm just
wondering how many people in this room
have electric vehicles
oh there are two there are two just out
of it just out of Interest that's all
right
uh agenda item 7s the question number
six from a member regarding parks and
Open Spaces I have had apologies from
councilor Huxley and so she will receive
an a written answer from Council gender
item seven uh uh G then question number
seven from a member regarding
Environmental Protection and Housing
Development I call upon councilor Smith
really good thank you
um thank you
um
to quote uh the rspb that radical
organization England
this government has launched an attack
on nature
the UK government's recent mini budget
included plans for investment zones
where planning permission would be
easier to get
plans have also been announced for a
sunset clause on Environmental
Protections introduced when the UK was
in the EU
alongside suggestions that the planned
environmental Land Management scheme
which would have paid Farmers to improve
nature on the land is to be scrapped and
rumors that payment by acre will no
longer be linked to any environmental
measures
the experience with the schotten Dane
road development this year demonstrated
that our powers to protect the
district's landscape environment and
quality of life are already weak what
assurances can you give us that the
council remains committed to sustainable
environmental policy in thanet in the
face of central government's agenda to
promote economic growth at all costs
by enabling unlimited Housing
Development I'm sorry I was addressing
councilor papers
uh thank you very much this is I believe
to the leader councilor Ashby to respond
very well
Council Bay for that answer it just as
adequately as as I will
remain committed well
we remain committed to a sustainable
environmental policy in bannett in line
with legislation government guidance and
our local own local plan
the scope of our current work to review
the local plan includes environmental
issues and climate change and the
adoption of any revised policies will be
a matter for full Council to consider in
due course
investment zones do not promote economic
growth at all costs
they are specifically targeted at
identified Geographic locations proposed
by local councils they aim to enhance
the opportunities for economic growth
which those spec at those specific
locations
although there is currently limited
detail about the way in which investment
zones will work it is clear they will
aim to reduce the tax burdens in
investment zones to help promote
economic growth and establish a bespoke
approach to planning accelerating
delivery of needed infrastructure homes
and jobs
these Innovations will only apply within
the specific boundaries of identified
investment zones our Zone proposal focus
on economic growth with the aim of
creating jobs that our local community
thank you very much indeed leader
councilor Smith do you have a
supplementary
yes it might be a little
bit
of
what I want to know is to what extent
can we resist
the the rolling back of environmental
legislation or the weakening of of
environmental legislation
in order to protect our environment as
well as our economy
thank you thank you but I do really
think that's one for central government
nevertheless if the leader would like to
respond
yes I would just like to confirm that um
there's a lot of misconception around
environment uh these investment zones
um unfortunately it because the
government haven't actually stipulated
specific details regarding the whole
matter
it has been somewhat hijacked by certain
groups to actually use this as a stick
in which to beat everyone with the
investment zones are not at all to
enable the absolutely abolition of
either building regulations or even
environmental regulations we as a
council can only follow the guidelines
and the specific laws of this of the
land so therefore I'm unable to actually
confirm whether or not there's anything
other than we can do other than remain
within the law within this Council thank
you chair thank you very much indeed
leader councilor bayford I've got
another one coming your way
question number eight from a member
regarding trees I call upon Council
Austin
thank you chair
question for me for a change Council
bayford we all know trees are important
for carbon capture Cooling and heat
waves biodiversity and our well-being
than it has the lowest tree cover in
Kent yet mature trees are regularly
felled both for development and other
reasons and replacing them is a
challenge please could you tell us how
members and residents can find out when
local trees particularly those with
protection orders are under threat of
felling
how long it typically takes to place a
protection order on a tree and what
protection that confers in practice
whether we're considering making more
TDC land available to community groups
wanting to plant and maintain trees
and how and when we plan to replace our
Horticulture and biodiversity officer a
consultant undertaking desk based
assessments from Devon seems inadequate
for the task at hand thank you
thank you Council Austin councilor
bayford
thank you I mean I I thought our
constitution said one question and the
supplementary are counted at least three
in there but never mind so okay all
applications for Works to protected
trees or notices for work to trees and
conservation areas published on the
council's website with a site notice
posted at the site where the work is
proposed the council is not required to
be informed of work to unprotected trees
in the district
the time taken to serve a TPO depends on
multiple factors including carrying out
as an assessment of the tree or group of
trees and legal checks on ownership and
serving of the order
the couch was recently employed a
planning assistant for trees who is
processing applications and
notifications whilst also progressing
through the request for new tpos
received
a TPO restricts the ability of an owner
to carry out Works to a tree with
limited exceptions without first
submitting an application to the council
new tpos are provisionally placed for
six months with the council required to
confirm a TPO within that time to make
an order permanent
DDC will have a clearer picture of where
trees can be planted on TDC Land by next
spring in Readiness for the Autumn 23
spring 24 planting season
we aim to create a map of where
Community groups can plant trees so
groups can plan their projects
tdc's graft has drafted a community tree
planting protocol which we ask Community
groups to follow an online application
form has also been created we ask
Community groups to consider all aspects
of tree planting and ask for proof that
they have consulted with local community
groups town councils or have a clear
plan to do so confirmation that they
will purchase the trees from companies
which have a biosecure stock
confirmation that they have full
resources to establish the trees for
three years after planting it's
important important that they undertake
watering over the first three year
period
a new officer role within the council
was Open Spaces team is anticipated to
be created and filled next year
replacing the previous Horticultural and
biodiversity officer
their role will span tree advice for
planning and tree surveys and health and
safety in council's Open Spaces in the
meantime the planning department is
using the consultant to provide detailed
another shiftry applications and
planting I'm sorry planning applications
which affect trees when required in
support of the new planning assistant
for trees this is included and continued
to include site visits to assess tree
works when required
thank you thank you councilor bayford
and you answered those three questions
very well Council Austin do you have a
supplementary question
I'm not sure I dare with uh with Council
Davis reaction there thank you very much
that was I'm particularly encouraged
about the uh the plans for land and
community plan uh planting there and and
we'll pass that on to community groups I
think a number of us are concerned about
knowing more about when tree trees with
protection orders in our own Wards are
threatened with felling is there any way
that we can amplify the information that
goes out to members and to the community
about that I know there are site notices
but often they're they're not very
visible are there ways we could could
improve that at all councilor Beaufort
thank you councilor Austin a sort of
supplementary question in there for you
councilor bayford yeah I I mean I have
to say that that's not not something
I've specifically thought about it's
something we can look at but I mean as
we've already said I mean it's published
on the council's website notices are put
up so I would have thought you know with
your with World counselors
um Keen observation skills they would
notice these things or their networks
would inform them of these so you know I
mean I don't know really what else we
can do
but I'll ask a question
thank you councilor bayford question
number nine from a member regarding the
cost of living crisis I call upon
councilor ference
thank you chair
um according to the index of multiple
deprivation
sorry
I'll start again it's leference it's
normal to stand oh I'm sorry I noticed
that councilor Whitehead didn't stand
and it's easier for me to yes otherwise
I'd have to hold this at a funny angle
all right we'll let that go fine I'll
let that go this evening
you'll let it go
right
so my question is according to the index
of multiple deprivation for England
than it continues to rank as the most
deprived local Authority in Kent
in particular Margate Central ranks 67th
out of 32
844 local areas that's 67th out of 32
844 areas it's closely followed by
cliftonville West at 117th and Newington
at 284th
clearly these figures illustrate that we
have extremely high levels of children
in poverty homelessness
unemployment and benefits claimants and
rough sleepers
this cost of living crisis sometimes
known as the cost of capitalism crisis
will hit thousands of our residents and
their well-being and put them in a very
dangerous position
many people are very fearful about how
they'll be able to find the money
to stay warm this winter and find enough
to eat
therefore could the council please
outline its plans
to support the thousands of residents
suffering deprivation particularly our
children and elderly and disabled
through the coming winter months thank
you
thank you Council farence before I move
I just simply mentioned that the matter
of rising is just a courtesy to council
which normally speaking we do encourage
nevertheless I call upon the leader to
respond
thank you chair
well it's impossible for me to list the
good work that this Council does for the
residents of thanet but for your
specific question
the council has already administered
over 8.7 million pounds worth of support
to almost 58 000 households in the
district in the form of council tax
energy rebate payments with payments of
150 pounds being made to all households
in properties band D and below
over and above this we've also provided
target support through our very own
discretionary energy rebate scheme this
discretionary scheme has allocated 371
000 and benefited almost 10 000
households in the district
staying on the theme of council tax
support it is important to recognize
that we continue to have one of the most
generous local council tax support
schemes in the country
our scheme provides up to 90 relief for
working age residents helping those on
low income pay their council tax
the council will also continue to
provide support in the form of
discretionary housing payments making
extra payments to Residents receiving
housing benefit or the housing cost
element of Universal Credit who needs
the sorry who need the most help with
their housing costs
the council has provided over 460 000
through our household support fund with
this scheme being used to provide
support to just under 5 000 households
this includes direct financial support
to pensioners with energy bills also
approximately 1500 well and warm packs
which include money and energy saving
Essentials such as microwave ovens the
third trance of the household support
fund is due to be rolled out over the
autumn and winter period
our housing options team will continue
to financially assist households who are
threatened with homelessness in various
ways including assisting them to pay off
rent arrays to sustain their tenancy
support with going through budget plans
and personal housing plans helping with
the rent in advance and deposit towards
new accommodation
our rise team which recently secured
funds and until March 2025 also provide
food vouchers phones moving packs
initial Gas and Electric top-ups donated
items Furniture as well as giving help
with food Parcels signposting to food
banks all designed to help someone from
rough sleeping into a sustainable home
our tenant and leaseholder services
include a financial well-being team who
can support our tenants with managing
their finances and accessing all of the
benefits they are entitled to
in the private sector we are providing
support for people experiencing through
fuel poverty to access funding for
energy efficient improvements and taking
action against landlords who fail to
provide adequate Heating and insulation
at this point I would like to add that I
think the council officers do an
absolute fantastic job in this Council
for and for the residents of thanet and
they are working extremely hard to
provide the support that is needed and
they also have to administer when the
government decides to
um
to add additional grants onto the
existing framework they also have to
administrate that which they had to do
on top of their already huge workloads
and also I'd like to actually say at
this point as well that our rise team do
a superb job in this district and they
go out in all weathers all times of the
night and day so you know I think
they're doing everything they can the
council is doing everything they can and
I'm very well for one very proud of our
officers and the writing thank you
thank you
oh well said leader thank you very much
I come back to councilor ference do you
have a supplementary Council parents
I'm glad that
um
councilor Ashby has taken the
opportunity to show how well we're doing
and that my question has has enabled her
to do that that is very impressive
um what I what I am concerned about is
um us supporting food banks and the
possibility of that and also about
keeping people warm now we have very
empty Council Offices here there are
public buildings there's the library and
I wondered if there's any plans to
support our food banks more and also to
offer warm spaces to people for certain
times during this hard winter that we're
going to expect with the fuel prices
thank you thank you carrot Council of
fans back to you leader
I know this Council and the community
team are very supportive of the food
banks I believe that we actually provide
free accommodation for one of the food
banks from our own
estate property I believe that tenancy
is coming up shortly for is coming up
for ending but this Council does support
where it can
I will in find out whether or not there
are any plans for the council building
itself to be a warm Hub
um I I actually thought about it the
other day to think that whether or not
that would be something that we could
facilitate and I will take it up with
the community team
thank you very much indeed leader that
concludes our questions for this evening
before I move on I just simply mention
that I'm not measuring anybody in
particular but it is normal procedure to
stand when asking and replying to a
question it's a courtesy to the council
and to all councilors who would be
responding yeah
yeah anyway I would like to be seen as
discourteous because I think
I'm pleased to hear that many
misunderstandings well you can make good
cake sold
um my leader and Mr Hughes in the past
about my difficulties so I'm sorry if I
didn't make it perfect enough well my
apologies if you have a particular
difficulty councilor parents and in the
circumstances I think that's understood
by everybody uh councilor Everett
I I just wanted to clarify that we have
had this conversation about councilor
Whitehead on a number of occasions and
that that's been as she's personally
been referred to you've understood the
fact that she has difficulty standing up
I don't think it's an appropriate thing
for us to keep going on about thank you
councilor Everett well taken and in
councilor whiteheads case I do
understand and anybody who has a
disability problem or anything like that
likewise that would be understood
agenda item 8 notice of motion now one
notice of motion has been received in
accordance with Council procedure rule
three please note that the time allowed
for consideration of motion shall not
exceed 30 minutes and I ask members to
be as succinct as possible
so we have under this agenda item eight
a motion regarding water supply and
treatment I call upon Council Smith who
is bringing this motion
it's me again
um thank you Chad
at the risk of stating the obvious and I
don't need to read the whole motion do I
because that will take a long okay good
at the risk of stating the obvious water
is an essential substance without which
we don't survive
and
in my motion I
quoted uh Ian McCauley the former CEO of
Southern water who describes than it as
water stressed and I believe that what
he meant was
there may not be enough
clean fresh water
to keep us
safe
and well alive
93 percent of the drinking water in town
it relies on one aquifer
um
and
plus than its local economy depends on a
safe and inviting sea for ourselves and
for visitors
Southern water is currently required
only to comment on on the availability
of the pipes not on the the capacity to
treat waste water
we're not proposing policy we're not
proposing that we impose policy on the
officers who deliver it but we are
proposing that we at least request
the information that is necessary for
the planning committee to make informed
decisions
about housing development specifically
similar motions to this one have been
recently passed in Lewis in Wilton in
mendip and Cambridge City I believe
um
sorry
okay
um
in many cases this received
wide cross-party support in some cases
unanimous cross-party support
always received a lot of press coverage
and massive public support
and I believe that it is in our
interests to be seen to support this
motion thank you
councilor Smith would you actually like
to read out the detail of your proposed
motion
you're leaving you are leaving that bit
um I wasn't I wasn't going to because I
was informed that I didn't need to so I
had it well more or less added well you
don't hear the
you don't need to but you had 20 seconds
left nevertheless
uh is there a seconder for that motion
who do I have councilor Austin are you
seconding thank you would members please
note that in accordance with Council
procedure rule 3.7 if the motion is
seconded then there will be referred
cabinet as it relates to a cabinet
function unless Council decides to
debate the motion now if Council wishes
to debate the motion then following
debate the motion will be referred to
Cabinet in accordance with Council
procedure through
3.84 in accordance with the council
procedure Ruth 3.7 a member of the
controlling political group is entitled
to reply therefore leader councilor
Ashby would you like to make a reply
thank you chair not really sure what I'm
replying to but um all I can do is is
actually inform counselor about the work
that I've already done with Southern
water as you're all aware I introduced
Ian McAuley to this Council he did a
members briefing there have been various
meetings there are all sorts of um
there's activity going on Pathfinders
projects which I'm uh the top I'm
actually on the task team for that so I
represent than it at that we have
um the thanet water users Group which
regularly meets to discuss various
issues I mean I can come out there's all
sorts of facts and figures where we are
involved and we do hold Southern water
to account I think that was demonstrated
by the hundred thousand pounds that was
actually obtained from Southern water in
compensation to the council for the
distress that it calls the council and
and the actual tourism industry at the
time
we have blue flag Awards we have Seaside
Awards and
it's a I appreciate a consent
contentious subject but all I can do is
assure Council that they are being held
to account on a regular basis in fact
Toby Willison met with the fishermen
which I arranged last last month so they
are very we are very active with them
there are various Subs programs but the
underlying fact for than it is that our
issue here is very simple
we do not have a rainwater separation
system in this District our problem is
not with the new builds in this District
our problem is with our existing stock
and that is the hard fact if we built
tanks that constitute 12 swimming pool
sizes
in thanet then that would be where we
would actually eliminate the problems
with the treatment works and that is
that is the hard fact now unfortunately
this Council for 15 years ago turned
down the planning permission to do such
that so we are sort of Engineers of our
own fate but one thing I would add and
the point that you make about
acknowledge that this Council cannot
acknowledge that the water quality has
deteriorated we cannot do that but I
will say as a personal from a personal
residence I water skied a fullness Point
30 35 years ago and I often visit now
still go down there and go and have
water skied up to very recently and I
can assure you the water quality is a
hundred times better than it was 35
years ago
and that's not defending Southern water
that is just stating the fact
thank you very much indeed leader do I
have a counselor wishes to debate the
meeting proposed debating
counselor I can't see you
councilor Austin sorry Council Austin I
couldn't quite see do you have a
seconder for that
to debate the motion and I do have
councilor wing
uh two counter counselors agreed to
debate the motion
no
I think I better have a show of hands
those in favor to debate the motion
those in favor of not debating emotion
thank you
okay
so that's uh that's not agreed to delay
the motion I've just been informed
that's not agreed to debate the motion
and in consequence uh it'll just be
referred to Cabinet as is usual thank
you very much indeed uh moving on to
agenda item nine the leaders report call
upon the leader councilor Ashby
sorry chair you're just scooting through
this agenda art
catching up are you
yeah
he's under strict orders
anyone think I had and I'll read this is
this
as quickly as I can due to the sad
passing of our wonderful queen Queen
Elizabeth II I was unable to deliver my
original version which I've now updated
for this reconvene meeting
it will come as no surprise to you all
that my opening item is to express my
delight that the Secretary of State for
transport has granted the dco for Manson
Airport
one thing we did agree on at the last
council meeting was for the government
to make a decision either way Council
Auburn you did request that I write to
the government and express our
frustration with it today whereby I did
write the following day to Greg Clarke
and lo and behold a few weeks later here
we have it
the conservative group have always
supported the reopening of manston
airport and now as the leader of thanet
council I'm proud of the fact that
private investors have the confidence
and believe to invest in our district
I'm sure we are the Envy of other
councils that 400 million are private
investment or if you like leveling up
funds are winging their way towards us
in addition to the creation of jobs it
will also give local people access to
training and re-skilling allowing wider
opportunities of employment something
not often spoken about is the business
rate income stream to TDC which it will
come from the reopening of the airport
and Associated businesses
I believe that the reopening of Manson
airport is something that most residents
of thanet want to see I suppose we'll
only get to know that on the 5th of May
2023.
the completion of the sale of the
Granville theater in Ramsgate is nearly
complete and as we know now as we now
know the new owner has been selected
with the final legal process well
underway to take the sale through to
completion
the prospective buyer selected following
a was selected following a robust
evaluation process is Westwood One
limited a local run organization
family-run organization
their proposal will see the theater
refurbished to provide a high quality
production dance and Cinema space
management of the Winter Gardens has now
been returned to the council temporary
security screening has been installed
and fencing put in place to protect and
preserve the building with security
measures including daily patrols
internal inspections and CCTV
contrary to claims from certain quarters
this is now our opportunity to take a
good look with fresh eyes at the Winter
Gardens and find the ideal solution to
determine how clear and long-term future
for the venue
it was agreed at cabinet on the 22nd of
September for the first phase of studies
to go ahead which will include a code
sorry costage structural survey a
complete set of site drawings and
encouraging a team of Consultants to
conduct a review of the Margate
nighttime economy
this will support the council to go out
to the marketplace to understand the
interests for a Leisure provision
project discussion discussion between
thanet Rotary Club and TDC alongside a
donation from Southern water good old
southern water have enabled 12 New
Recycling stations to be installed
across our main bathing beaches this
summer
the first emptying of the bins produced
three tons of recycling all of which
have been kept away from landfills or at
sea
thanks go to officer Mark Greening for
the sourcing and installation of the
bins
the multi-agency litterpick took place
at Margate Sands a few days back
when I joined a few days back which I
joined it was a few days it was more
than that now so sorry I should have
corrected that a bit which joins to a
little pick and engage with Beach
visitors along with the council's
community team Margate task force Kent
fire rescue service local litter picking
group rise up clean up and volunteers
between us we collected 34 bags of
rubbish and 10 bags of recycling in just
one hour
I did actually catch a shot but that's a
story for another day
staying on the same subject to the
environment our Open Spaces team have
been undertaking by the diversity work
at Ramsgate Cemetery they have installed
bird boxes created habitats by planting
trees and reusing natural materials such
as logs and tree stumps wildflowers have
been planted to attract pollinators and
Woodland walk has been installed for
visitors
I did actually volunteer to water the
young trees at Jackie Bakers during the
August Heatwave so the tree officer
could take a well-earned holiday
the trees were planted in March and as
part of as part of the Queen's canopy
project and my thanks go to my co-pilots
councilor George Carr and and Charlie
Dench for riding shotgun and to the Open
Spaces team for entrusting their truck
and Bows a tank to me
which I did return unscathed Ellington
Park in Ramsgate was a 40 awarded the
green flag award a first for parks in
thanet this follows its Restoration in
2021 through a partnership agreement
between the friends of Ellington Park
and sanit District Council which with
funding from the National Lottery
lottery Heritage fund
finishing off on this subject the draft
Net Zero strategy and action plan has
been produced which outlines how we
achieve a reduction in the council's
core carbon footprint to Net Zero by
2030.
it is an excellent report and puts our
Council up there leading the way
recognition should go to Dr Hannah Scott
for her hard work putting this together
and portfolio holder councilor Bob Baker
for his input and steering it through
the process
I also attended the ceremony whereby the
Margate Charter trustees conferred Tracy
Emin to the title of honorary freewoman
of Margate this was awarded as
recognition of the valuable contribution
that Tracy has made to the town
by living and working here Tracy has
certainly increased margate's profile
and the Regeneration of the town
Tracy Yemen's name will be added to the
Margate Charter trustee honors board it
marks the first time that the title of
ordinary freewoman has been bestowed in
the 50-year history of the Margate
Charter trustees and it will be listed
alongside the likes of Winston Churchill
who became a freemate Freeman of Margate
in 1957.
we have been awarded 3.8 million of
funding by the department for leveling
up housing and communities through the
rough sleeping initiative this
three-year funding means that we can
plan further ahead and allow for earlier
intervention to help prevent vulnerable
people from becoming rough sleepers and
to support current rough sleepers into
accommodation thank you chair
thank you very much leader I call upon
councilor Everett comment on or ask
questions in relation to the leaders
report
thank you chair and I'm thankful leader
for the advanced copies of our report
I recognize that there have always been
and continue to be strong and sincere
views about Manson on both sides of the
argument Council knows where this labor
group stands
but we all agree that this issue has
been a blight on planet for far too long
I have a new measurement for delay and
it's called the Tory prime minister
it was three prime ministers ago under
David Cameron when the airport shut and
Rivera River Oak first said it would
submit a DCR it was two leaders ago when
Theresa May was prime minister that we
had the dco examination stage and it was
one leader ago under Boris Johnson when
the dco was granted in July 2020
question early 2021 and now granted
again 18 months later
I very much doubt that the airport will
be opening under Liz trust and you could
interpret that whichever way you like
of course jobs and investment are vital
for fanatic which is why the labor
Administration prioritized Ramsgate port
for the leveling up bid and lobbied
Harper Parkway station
it's a shame that councilor Ashby didn't
also mention in her report the very real
concern is that many people in Ramsgate
have regarding manston about their
quality of life about environmental
damage about the tourist industry and
about residents rights of sleep
and since she mentioned investment zones
in relation to the business trade so she
mentioned business rates in related to
Madison airport should that become an
investment zone of course people get the
business rates no probability but we
don't know that because the government
then told us what it means
she didn't mention that even more
agricultural land will have to be
allocated for new housing which could be
built on the airport because there
simply Aren't Enough Brownfield sites
elsewhere anything to accommodate you in
fact there's a real risk the council has
to allocate more rural sites and then
the airport still doesn't go ahead
there will be no going back on those
allocations just there isn't that just
as there is no going back on the current
plan as a matter of law not as a policy
to be decided by this Council now or in
the future
the leader seems to think that next
May's local elections will be a public
verdict on the airport I admire her
optimism
thank you
funnily enough we had an election
earlier this year in medical
which Council the pipe and tried to turn
into a referendum on the airport and I'm
very grateful to him for that
I suspect most voters next mayor will be
more worried about feeding their
families about the cost of heating their
homes and indeed whether they will still
have one
I want to welcome the successful bib for
the Granville theater and wish the new
owners every success I also want to
praise the work done by the East Cliff
Ward councilors especially councilor
Crittenden who unlike others did not
align themselves to one particularly
vocal bidder but sought to understand
and clarify the process being followed
and raise concerns they had with cabinet
and officers
I don't think the council's handling of
this matter is beyond criticism but it
is clear that opposition counselors were
in no position to assess the merits of
one publicized proposal against others
because of the proper need for
confidentiality
I was intrigued to be told that it had
been revealed on Facebook that my sister
would put in a bid
not so much because she hadn't told me
but because I didn't know I had a sister
I've had a Stern world with my mother
but it turns out she didn't know either
however it's understandable when
residents see a positive plan for the
building that is widely promoted they
smell something wrong when they're told
its proponents couldn't get a proper
hearing and I don't blame the public for
that we look forward to seeing the
Granville brought back into use by the
community very soon and the same goes
for the ongoing work around the Winter
Gardens
I want to welcome the Net Zero strategy
and action plan which follows on from
Labor's climate emergency motion the
work of the cabinet Advisory Group and
the employment of our first climate
change officer this plan is a big step
forward and I commend all those who have
contributed to it including the cabinet
member
but if fracking Drilling in the North
Sea and scrapping environmental laws are
all part of the latest conservative
government's policy I do wonder how our
own leader will be able to reconcile the
local and National agenda
finally the leader tells us about the
3.8 million three-year funding for the
rough sleeping initiative and it's good
to be able to plan
what she doesn't say is that the council
was allocated 1.8 million for the single
year 2021-22 and that the problem is
increasing fast so what we've actually
been given is a big cash production even
without taking Rising need or inflation
into account once again it is the weaker
members of society who suffer because of
a conservative decision that is the
context of their efforts to cut taxes
for the better off and while I can't
blame counselor s before it I will say
that it stinks
thank you well thank you very much Dean
Council effort I think we enjoyed some
of that it's quite well put together
councilor Ashby would you like to
respond not sure I can follow that chair
um
well what I meant by the airport
um about the fifth of May next year
wasn't necessarily A positive or A
negative so um uh we'll have to see
um unfortunately
um we'll probably all beholden to what
happens in central government as opposed
to actually whether they're there are
more residents that want the airport or
don't want it I agree with you as well
the Granville
um the it's an absolute fantastic result
for for the district and it was
um obviously enabled us to see the
actual process and how things should
should be processed and the fact that it
was all um decided by an independent
panel as well
um actually made it all the more if you
like processed pure and we followed the
process and we did follow the process
um the um
other part about the fracking and uh and
I can't be held to account for that so I
don't really know I don't really have a
stance on that all I know is that we
should never have become beholden to
Russia and and if we hadn't have done
then we probably wouldn't be where we
are now but we are where we are now and
quite frankly I'm very very concerned
about the situation out there so um we
can sort out our own issues locally and
I like to concentrate on issues locally
but it does pale into somewhat
insignificance when you see the plight
of what is going on out there so um I
just uh I just hope that we can find a
sensible solution and we don't and we
can get back to dealing with business
for our own Council in a way that uh
made sense thank you for your response
cancer
thank you leader uh councilor Gardner
have you got something Lively for us as
well
I'm sure I can be quite that Lively but
I'll see what I can do
I'd like Council effort like to start as
usual by thanking the leader for early
sight of a report to allow us to prepare
our responses although as she said
standing up to deliver these responses
has been sadly delayed by the death of
the late Queen
um you won't be surprised to hear that
though not entirely surprised we were
deeply disappointed that the Secretary
of State saw fit to approve a new AK
I'll go Hub at manston at a time in our
rapidly worsening climate emergency has
never been obvious to all of us from
Heat Wave and drought even in the
temperate UK to disastrous floods in
Pakistan
the government decision was taken
despite evidence from their own experts
that there is no need for a cargo Hub
and that it will blight the beautiful
town of amscape for which as a council
we've developed such exciting plans
through the vansgate future program
there's been much mystery about the
source of the 500 million or or is it
now 600 million investment needed to
fund this misadventure and we suspect it
is likely to appear as River Oaks
prediction of thousands of new local
jobs a prediction at odds with the 200
posts currently involved in running
South End airport a number which sadly
looks set to be reduced now that Amazon
are pulling it pulling out citing
reciting concerns about the climate
impact of Aviation
we certainly recognize that more high
quality jobs and training opportunities
are needed in thanet which is why we are
delighted that the development of green
Hub at gramsgate Port forms part of our
leveling up program giving up access to
sustainable jobs for the future rather
than harking back to the past
we're pleased to see The long-running
Saga of the Granville territories at an
end at last and we wish the new owner
Westward won limited luck with their
plans
the leader is aware though that we do
have concerns about the process that was
followed here this has been a chapter of
accidents and miscommunications
culminating and unsuccessful bidders
who had committed considerable time to
work out their bids receiving the news
that they were not successful in a
four-line text
this is not the way community groups
with exciting ideas for the future of a
council asset should be treated even if
we have chosen an alternative project
at this point
overall we think there is a need for
much greater Clarity and transparent
currency over our asset transfer and
Disposal process
as evidenced by the difficulty some
colleagues have had getting any
information at all on what's happening
with places like the Spencer Square Cafe
and Tennis Courts we hope the Winter
Gardens will serve as an opportunity for
us to do better with our processes and
Communications with interested parties
and the public so we can develop a
process we and residents all understand
and feel happy with
we're delighted to see the publication
of our ambitious and comprehensive Net
Zero strategy and wish to congratulate
Dr Anna Scott councilor Bob bayford and
everyone else involved in developing
this as ever the acid test will be how
we deliver it and whether we can get
partners on board
we would urge cabinet and Senior
officers to ensure we cooperate as fully
as possible without other agencies and
learn from other councils as this field
develops
and you might be surprised to hear us
suggest that the increasing number of
green lid councils across the country
from Lewis to Lancaster definitely worth
following for examples of good practice
it was great also to hear positive news
on Recycling and tree planting
and we'd like to thank all the officers
and members involved and the rotary for
their recycling initiative to pursue
both this effective Community engagement
and help us move toward Net Zero we
would urge cabinet and Senior officers
to identify places where more Community
tree planting initiatives can take place
to the local local groups who want to
lead on these schemes can fulfill their
Ambitions and help improve our low
levels of tree cover across the district
and finally as we move into what is
likely to be a very challenging Autumn
winter for many of our residents
we welcome the funding for the rough
sleeping initiative
even though as highlighted earlier by
Council Everett we do need to recognize
that year on year is a reduction on the
amount we've receive for this year
providing support like this for the most
vulnerable in our communities is going
to become a higher priority and we as a
council will need to be thinking more
creatively about ways in which we can
provide that essential support thank you
thank you very much indeed councilor
Connor leader do you have a response
thank you chair
say that um the process of asset
disposals is complicated and it is also
highly confidential because of the
nature you can't release information
with bidders etc etc because that is
detrimental to them and their own data
protection and privacy
so as soon as it was known
um that
um where the award was going and when it
was safe to do so then that's when the
news came out
unfortunately
um I can't agree with you on the process
I think the process was followed very
well
um unfortunately being in business and
of having been an actual fact in any of
us that have applied for jobs where
we've just had a one Tech the one-line
text to tell us that we've been
unsuccessful unfortunately that is the
way of life and other than just
notifying unsuccessful bidders that is
very common practice in in the private
sector as well as it is in the in the
public sector in fact I think the public
sector probably say a lot more than the
private sector do
um it's uh good to hear about the
support for for all the green
initiatives obviously you're going to
come from that from that direction
um the only thing that I struggle with
is that
um we need houses to home people but
they need to plant trees and and the two
sort of don't really marry from that
point and we are very short of land yes
they do we are very short of land can
you allow me to finish and we know that
the priority in order to move people
from the rough sleeping onto initiatives
of finding them work and finding them
places to live is a petrol per petrol
problem of actually providing housing as
councilor Whitehead as as often said
that we need to provide more housing
more affordable housing so we have to
find the balance within the within the
district but I thank you for your
comments
thank you very much indeed leader I call
upon councilor Reverend Stuart Piper to
comment on or ask questions in relation
to the leaders report councilor Piper
thank you John thank you leader for your
report
um there's some very interesting points
that have already been I think very well
covered uh by my colleagues I would just
like to add that I think our local
councils or all of them treated the
notices of the Queen's death and the
proclamation of the accession of King
Charles III with dignity and Grace and
served our community very proud
moving on to some of the substances of
the substances if
remarks in your report
um
I agree with you I believe the reopening
of Manson airport is something that most
residents in thanet want to see
Independence it may be worth my while
taking the opportunity to remind
everybody we owe our existence because
of our promise made as ukip candidates
on Manson airport and when the time came
for us to take decisive action to ensure
that they had a final chance to achieve
that we took the action we needed to and
now we are where we are and we look
forward to hearing lots of lovely
aircraft and other business activity
going on on that site Sue I would add
that I do in fact live under the flight
path
or not to mention the jobs I do believe
the 200 jobs at the airport that were
mentioned are those who work directly on
site there are thousands of other
ancillary jobs associated with the
airport
um with regard to the Winter Gardens it
is very sad of course the state that
it's in at the moment but I respect that
the council is doing its level best to
try and improve the situation for myself
on behalf of the planet Independence I
wrote To Sir Andrew Lloyd Webber and
asked if he would have any interest in
not only meeting with your leader but
providing some funding for developing
that site his office did reply that he
is having completed the alterations at
Drury Lane he's involved in another one
at the moment and didn't feel able to
commit resources at this time but he
thanked us for our support for that uh
iconic building
in the meanwhile we've had some
cross-party financial support from
councilor George rizeki councilor Linda
Piper and myself who have given a
donation of six thousand pounds to Saint
Mark's Church in Ramsgate it may
interest members to know that the size
of the stage in Saint Mark's Church
matches that of the Winter Gardens and
so the donation was given to them to
enable them to carry out Lighting and
Sound improvements and be able perhaps a
little quicker than the Granville
theater to be able to offer an
alternative space for local people for
dance groups drama groups and so on but
I wonder leader would you be prepared to
invite Mr Kevin Spain from the church to
share a coffee and a chat with us to
fully explain what the church is trying
to do in order to help the community it
has now designated the stage as a
community project so I wonder if you'd
be kind enough to invite him
it has 200 seats as well
so it's a sizable
venue that we should make good use of
while we while we have the need
it's good to see that the trees that
have been planted in the last year
particularly those Under The Canopy are
many of them are surviving it's sad to
see when the local herberts decide to
break them but it's good to see that
many of them are surviving and we are
hoping to although we haven't got the
location exactly yet Ramsgate Town
Council is hoping indeed to plant a good
deal more trees within the locality
thank you very much for your report
um and for listening to me thank you
Chuck
thank you very much indeed councilor
Piper uh
leader would you like to come back on
that yes uh just thank you for your
positive comments on on the issues um
also yes I'll be delighted uh if you
would like to um
forward the details then I'll make
arrangements it would be good to have
um whilst we're sorting out the
provision for the Winter Gardens it
would be good to have an alternative
provision to to get us through the time
when um the whilst the temporary closure
of the Winter Gardens is is there thank
you Council
thank you very much indeed leader uh now
Council Piper I'm going to be calling
right back on you for agenda item 10 the
report from the chairman of the overview
and scrutiny panel councilor Piper
thank you again chair members I commend
the report to you we've had some time to
read it and consider it uh it is
essentially the same as the meeting we
had to curtail if there are any
questions that you would like to ask
please do so or if there's more detail
you want I happily invite anyone to
write to me on any particular subject
but I commend it to you and one of our
options is to note the report thank you
very much
thank you very much indeed Council Piper
and we as members will note the report
I'm sure
thank you very much indeed
gender item 11 changes to committees the
leader of the council has informed
Democratic services that she wishes to
replace councilor George cupp with
councilor Linda Wright as a member of
the governance and Order committee group
leaders may take this opportunity as
well to advise of any other changes to
their nominations to committees panels
and boards for the remainder of the
2022-2023 Year councilor Ashby do you
wish revise any further nomination
changes
nothing further thank you chair
councilor Everett do you wish to advise
of any domination changes no thank you
Jeff
councilor Garner do you wish to advise
of any nomination changes no thank you
chair
uh councilor Piper Jewish suicide of any
nomination changes no thank you chip
thank you very much indeed that
concludes the business for this first
meeting of the council this evening
now without any further to do and since
we've got a lot on the agenda and time
is pressing I'd like to move straight on
to the extraordinary meeting
uh